now tonight thousands of americans are
at the mercy of the taliban amid the
biden administration's unmitigated
unprecedented failures lack a commitment
to guaranteeing that all americans get
evacuated safely tonight we're following
the story of sabir nasir now he worked
as an afghan interpreter
for u.s forces for years he's living in
the u.s but he's desperately trying to
get his family out of afghanistan
joining us now to explain more along
with fox news contributor who's known
sabre for a long time our own sarah
carter uh sabre first our thoughts and
prayers are with your family what are
you hearing on the ground and there were
many thousands of people that were
promised by our government if this day
ever came we would get them out safely
is that correct
uh good evening everyone and thank you
sir uh yes
i fought for this country i serve 11
years for u.s marine corps
and
but now
i lost my fingers in the war
the taliban they cut my fingers off they
cut my bodies all that i got a lot of
shrapnels i work for navy seals u.s
marines in afghanistan but right now the
taliban
they are hunting my family because the
this country they made a documentary
movie about me i i won the hollywood
award amy award a lot of awards i want
and my family they're in a movie too
john and john allen and other other
colonels and generals that they work
with me the taliban they just cut my
cousin nick off a couple days ago that
they moved from baghlan province to
kabul and they are hunting my family my
family and my brother family they all
living close to the airport it become
one week i didn't sleep i didn't eat
good and i didn't
i'm i'm very worried about my family i
might i might lose my my family and i'm
asking from mr uh joe biden that he
broke his promise and he left my family
in other
american allies behind what's your
answer for humanity for me that i
support and sacrifice for this country
now i need your help what you will do
thank you
sarah um you know many people by the way
and our thoughts and prayers are with
your family tonight you know many people
like saber mr nasir and his family
um they were promises and then we have
untold thousands of americans we don't
know how many we just know they're
behind enemy lines how do you get told
to go to the airport we suggest you go
to the airport we can't guarantee your
safe passage to the airport okay not
very comforting to me it seems that we
are at the mercy now of this brutal
terrorist supporting organization and
terrorist organization
you're absolutely right sean it's
complete chaos i've been on the phone
all day and night uh sabre knows this
i've been talking to my friends people
that i consider family in afghanistan
just like sabre who have said that they
their their mothers have been beaten
their sisters have been beaten people
have been slaughtered outside the gates
i know right now people have even
arrived at the gates even with american
passports and visas to enter into kabul
airport and they've been turned away
because there's so much confusion at the
gates right now there were planes that
literally lifted off the ground today
with empty seats because nobody knows
who to let in or who to let out it
appears that even at the embassy
everything was burned even the visas so
when they destroyed everything they
destroyed all the information right now
on the ground people are trying to get
it together to get people out of the
country sean i just want to say one more
thing there are amazing americans who i
can't mention right now who are helping
people over there both americans and
afghan allies they are doing what they
can to get people out and uh that's
what's keeping our hopes up
oh there's thousands sarah thousands
saber we pray for your family and the
families of every american in harm's way
tonight